[Musique]
une nouvelle fois avec Emmanuel Macron
il y a loin des paroles aux actes la
semaine dernière le président de la
République reconnaissait qu'il y avait
bien un lien entre immigration et
délinquance donnant le chiffre de 50%
des actes de délinquance commis à Paris
sont le fait d'étranger il y a donc bien
un lien entre immigration et délinquance
et nous nous attendions est-ce que le
Président de la République durcisse les
règles en matière d'immigration mais que
nous proposons au final dans le texte
présenté par le ministre de l'Intérieur
et le ministre du Travail une fois de
plus dû en même temps quelques mesures
pour
faciliter le renvoi dans leur pays
d'origine des clandestins mais surtout
une proposition de régularisation qui
incontestablement
aperçu comme un appel d'air au lieu de
durcir les règles en matière
d'immigration le gouvernement veut au
contraire les facilités ce que le
ministre de l'Intérieur résume de façon
je dois dire un peu plus terrible être
gentil avec les gentils et méchant avec
les méchants face à l'immigration
clandestine il n'y a pas de en même
temps possible il faut au contraire
afficher de la fermeté clairement
revendiquer pour obtenir les résultats
que les Français attendent dans la
matière
[Applaudissements]